got a lot of snow to get rid
of time to get a new ouse built but
something I need right
now this summer I went ahead and dug a
couple different holes around the
property but my wrist was broken an
accident this
fall I'm starting to recover finally to
where I can you know start doing
projects like this and now I got to go
dig out all the blown in drifted snow
before I can get
started
here we go I'm into the hole now there's
the framing that I use to shore up the
sides that way when the ground sted it
can't just Slough in and be filling up
the
hole this might not seem like a very
fancy
bathroom but I look around and I
think man this is the perfect setting
feel like you're out here in the middle
of nowhere it's nice not too far walk
from my place but far enough you know
you don't want to have your ouse too too
close to your house you don't want the
smell you know although I'm going to use
some saw dust to keep the smell
down let's talk about it like it is you
know got to
[Music]
poop all right got this nice and uh dug
out here and good little workpace and
area Next Step go get some materials
start my build
hang on
[Music]
bud I'm going to head down into the
woods here find a spot to get myself all
the post and cross pieces that I'm going
to need for the structure of the
ouse oh yeah that's it right
there
all right this tree right here is nice
and dead it's got uh looks like all the
pieces that I'm going to
need you stay Neil you stay right there
good
boy this is what you call my lumber yard
right
here some people see the disadvantages
of living out in the
bush I look at the advantages of
it if I need to go get some wood to work
with it's right here in my
backyard all
right the goal is just to make a simple
ouse I'm just going to use what I got
around me Spruce poles and I kind of
like that look aesthetically as well
I've got all my pieces here for my ouse
they were all in one tree that gave me a
bunch of firewood too so just couldn't
get it better than
that slow up Neil let's get out of here
[Music]
buddy